[Music]
thanks everyone for being here and
hopefully everyone had a great
conference I know that we went through a
lot of things for the past couple of
days my name is Ray I'm a developer
advocate for the Google cloud platform
one my job is to bring some of the best
technologies that Google has to offer
both the products in the open-source
projects to the Java developers over the
world and I'd love to make that Java
experience the best experience for the
Java developers when you're using Google
cloud platform I'm also a Java champion
if you have any questions please please
contact me on Twitter and Saturn ISM and
today we have a special guest as well
Josh go for it hi everybody my name is
Josh long on a spring developer advocate
on the spring team I'm an open-source
engineer and a contributor I have the
dubious distinction of my 10 plus years
contribute to the very spring projects
being the number one top-ranked most
visible most prolific most highly lauded
most acclaimed contributor of bugs but
still number one number one number one -
all the products were talking to
contributor there is that I do training
videos I do books I just finished my
latest in grace book called cloud native
Java which is all about how to build
applications that survive and thrive in
the cloud in terms of Java and spring
booting spring cloud and cloud finding
all these other great technologies and
the book is something about which and
which about which I'm very proud it's a
book about how to build applications
that do the right thing in the cloud and
it did take a little longer than we'd
expected it might take it did take just
a little longer we thought give it a
privileged position within the community
we'd have it done within six months no
problem but it didn't point in fact take
just a little it took a little okay it
took two years all right it took two
years to get this done book out and
there's a big reason for that right and
I I lay the blame for that tardiness
that delay at the feet of the intense
deliberations that went on between us
the author team and the publisher
O'Reilly we spent an extra 18 months
deciding upon the animal for the cover
now anybody who knows anything about
O'Reilly books knows that it doesn't all
that much matter what's in the book
proper and has everything to do with
what's on the animal what's the animal
so we eventually settled upon a blue
eared Kingfisher it's a bird that is
indigenous or native to the Indonesian
Java
Islands it's a bird that is indigenous
or native to the Indonesian Java islands
and birds fly yes through the clouds so
it's a bird that
there's native to Java that flies
through the clouds it's a cloud native
java bird it's a bird never mind they'll
come it'll come give it time and at
pivotal I am a just like my friend rate
right here I'm a Java Chan but and we
care about helping developers yep so as
you may have probably seen for the past
couple of days we have so many different
services and products we can actually
consume and use we have everything from
compute from your application to
services for machine learning to big
data processing and all of these things
one of our goals actually to make this
the easiest things to access for Java
developers and also for spring
developers as well so one of the goals
that we had was we provide one of the
best integrations for spring and spring
foods to consume and use TCP services
and we actually work really hard and
together between Google engineers and
pivotal engineers to provide this new
project which is called spring cloud GCP
it is the open source project you can
find it on the the spring cloud
organization on the github repository
and we work really hard to make sure
that it is automatic for the spring boot
development and that's easy to use and
why don't we just get started and show
you what we got I think we showed all
right I'll take the lead if you don't
mind my friend so go for it let's uh
we're gonna build a new application
today and we're gonna do so my second
favorite place on the internet my first
favorite place on the Internet of course
is production I love production you
should love production you should go as
early and often as possible bring the
kids bring the family the weather is
amazing it's the happiest place on earth
it's better than Disneyland but if you
haven't been to production then you can
begin your journey here at start that
spring that IO if you need inspiration
in the early morning before a cup of tea
or coffee start that spring that IO if
your children are restless and can't
sleep start that spring that IO and if
you suffer from indigestion after a long
night of alcohol abuse and PHP start
that spring that IO so we're gonna build
a new service called the reservation -
service and this service is gonna take
advantage of Springs web support we're
gonna take advantage of the JBC
and my sequel support so we got that
JDBC
we can use actuated for observability we
can use Lombok to make java just a
little bit less like java a little bit
tedious if you will there's a number of
other supported languages here not the
least of which is Kotlin but you can
also choose groovy we're gonna choose
what else do we need my phone
we're gonna be running this application
using GCC services so you can't really
add GC support there we aren't your
support as well yeah right and I think
that's it that we need web at web my
sequel debut CRM data arrest data rest
repositories yep
okay there we are so that's a number of
selections for now that'll get us
started we'll add some more things as we
need to it early let's hit generate and
then I'll give us this new project that
I'm going to open up in my IDE so here I
am in the Downloads directory I'm gonna
unzip and open that's a little alias
that that just does that for me I'm
gonna open this up in my ID and any ID
works just fine I'm using IntelliJ how
many of use IntelliJ I'm just curious
how many views Eclipse also good stuff
hot sauce how about NetBeans NetBeans
Emacs you next very cool awesome so we
have a number of options here we're
gonna build a simple application and
we're gonna start this off with a sort
of like an enterprise a use case an
application that's talking to a sequel
database now can you see that fun that
should be legible yeah good ok so we're
gonna talk to an application that has
some sequin in and to do so we're gonna
take data I'd have a database read the
data into details that were to modify or
manage here on the client so we have a
detail if you will that just reads data
and prints they did out so we have a
simple object with two fields and I'm
going to use Lombok Lombok is this
compile time annotation processor
that'll synthesize things like the
Gators the setters the to string the
argue the constructors etc it'll do all
that stuff for me through these compile
time these annotations now I'm gonna
write a thing I'm going to write in an
object that's going to run when the
application starts up and so in order
for it to run when the application
starts up I want spring which is my
framework and I'm using here to call
this run method it's gonna see that my
object which I've annotated that
component implements the application run
or interface and it's going to give me
an opportunity to do whatever I want
when the application starts up passing
in the public static void main string
arguments array in that in that object
I'm telling spring to inject the
collaborating object this JDBC template
which is a an object I can use to talk
to sequel based databases and here I'm
gonna say mmm this JDBC Tembo dot query
select all from reservations alright and
when I get the results back I'm gonna
map each row that comes back into an
entity of type reservation so there we
are there's my application and I'm gonna
say for each result set row RS let's get
the ID and and the reservation name and
turn it into a new reservation so RS get
string reservation name alright so
there's our entity now of course this
can be better written with lambdas in
Java 8 there we are
now that API this the API we're using
the jb's template is very powerful it's
pin spring since 2001 or so so it's been
around forever and you'll see here in
the comments our very own Thomas R is
Brooke among many others Thomas Risberg
was a main contributor to this code this
class over the over long period of time
and the result of this is a collection
of reservations so I'm going to say
query dot for each and I'm gonna print
out the result so system.out.print line
and there we are there's my results now
and when this application starts up I'm
going to need to have a sequel schema
that I can use and I'm going to need to
have some sample data so I'm going to
tell spring boot to initialize the
database by running the script called C
schema dot sequel I'm going to create a
table called reservations when the
application starts up and I'm gonna
initialize it I'm gonna say you're gonna
have an ID that's gonna be big into not
null
Auto increments primary key and I'll
have a field called reservation name
reservation name it's going to be var
car 255 not know now I want to be able
to delete this I want to make sure I
delete it when the application starts up
if it already exists I'm going to say
drop table if exists reservations so
there we go that's gonna create the
schema Eid input to me and then I'm
going to I'm going to now initialize
some data so I'm going to say data
sequel and here I'm just gonna insert
some records into my database that we
have something with which to work so
insert into reservations reservation
name values Josh I'm gonna have ray and
we'll have some of our friends
all right there we go so there's our few
of our friends in the in the application
so now we have four records they were
going to write when the application
starts up I need to tell spring to run
this this script when it starts up I
need to tell it to run the script when
it runs up so I'm going to say
initialization mode equals always and
there we have it there I'm done right I
I'm all I don't have to do anything else
I mean I I'm missing one little thing it
occurs to me I'm missing her Oh where's
your theater base
yeah well hadn't I hadn't really gotten
around to that man so you don't have any
your local machine no no right that's
okay but you do have a Google Cloud
project I do all right let's go there
and check it out okay so cloud dot
console dot Google okay yeah very cool
so you are in the project why don't we
go and find cloud sequel so you do have
a cloud sequences which is great this is
our managed sequel database right so you
can actually create a database that has
either my sequel or a post Christ why
don't we click into it now there are
many different ways for you to connect
one of the ways that you can do it is by
using the IP address down there but you
don't really want to do that because
that is a public IP so rather than doing
that one of the best way to connect you
it I use the instant connection name in
order for you to use that what happens
behind the scenes is going to create a
new JDBC URL that actually configure is
a special SSL socket factory that will
actually interchange the certificate for
you in order to establish a secure
connection to the backend database now
in order for you to have that
functionality on the easiest way is
actually by using our starter that we
built for the spring cloud GCD project
and once you have the starter in the
dependency tree then you can actually
choose configure it so there should be a
configuration called the instance
connection name that you can refer to
yeah there we go so it's pay starting
and then you can specify the database as
well which is the one that you created I
think it's if you go up if you go to
databases right there that should show
you the database you have in the
instance and it's called
reservations all right sorry actual work
right I mean that should be right I
think that's it yeah okay let's give it
a go that's what happens right now yeah
life go wrong what could go wrong
who here think this would just work oh
well nobody no company no yeah exactly
well let's take a look so in this
connect it is running and oh my goodness
did you see that just that scroll bye
there it is it worked of course it
worked it's a demo what were you
expecting instead we have this but let's
focus on this for a second notice that
we have all these different connections
here all these different connections
this application has got a whole bunch
of connections to talk to the database
so we can tune the connectivity
parameters here in the same way we would
anything else by specifying properties
on spring boots data source
configuration here I'm going to say I
want to have a maximum of two threads
alright so when that's gonna restart we
should see that we'll have considerably
less output on the console when the
application starts up but that is
working we're actually talking to a
database in the cloud we can see that
right see that here not enough from here
not from here so wait there we go he's
got the data we got the database we got
the auto incremented ID and all that
stuff that's been done for us that's
working just fine I'm a big fan of my
secret but you know I hear that even
even Google moved away from my sequel
format for Adwords years ago they had a
they had global consistency problems
they want to make sure they had enough
that data that was visible across all
those data centers across all the world
and the ones that have extremely
consistent distributed transactions so I
heard that they had this thing called
spanner which sounds like a really smart
idea but as I understand it I need
atomic clocks and GPS receivers right
and that sounds like a real doesn't
sound like something I want to manage
yeah yeah so so we actually have spanner
the database that is probably available
probably distributed it strongly
consistent relational database that you
can use on the cloud on GCP it's called
cloud spanner now to use classman or
sometimes you may have to use the API
but what we have done with spring cloud
GCP is to actually integrate this with
spring cloud data or spring data spring
data force better so one of the things
that we can do is actually why don't we
go ahead and open up the the pomme de
XML and so what I'm going to do is to
just get rid of some of these my sequel
stuff so I'm going to say there we go
maybe let me get rid of that for now and
then the JDBC starter we don't need that
for the next one and I do need to change
out the distorter
right there what happened oh yeah
ctrl-click Tintin I dig man
your um your keyboard so hard to use I
there we go
so where did it go let me open this up
again found like smell all right so to
you sprint data I'm going to switch out
this dependency right here I'm just
gonna use starter data and spanner
now this starter is actually in a newer
version of the spring cloud GCP project
so I'm just gonna update the project to
one point one point zero this is
something you can actually try today as
well and actually bringing the right
dependencies once we have that down I
can go back to this application I can go
back to this Pocho and I can't really
just start to map this pojo into the
spanner tables so what that will allow
you to do is to you know not having to
use the raw API is when you don't
actually need to so the first thing I'm
looking to do is to just map it to a
spanner table with an add table
annotation for the primary keys we can
use the spring ID annotation here but
because spanner may actually require you
to use a composite key for parent
children relationships because we want
you to use composite keys with multiple
primary keys that has interleaving in
between so we actually have an
additional annotation here for primary
key with a few should be the database
because when you show the data globally
one of the things that we don't want you
to do is to use a monotonically
increasing ID so the transition along
IDs you probably don't want to use
anymore and what we're going to use you
should be using a randomly generated
UUID instead and of course for the
columns we can map this to a column on
the spanner table as well but you know
sometimes the name doesn't match the
name of the field so we can also use the
annotation here for example we can call
it reservation on the score nian and
that's really it now we actually have to
go and create the spinner database so
I'm gonna go back to the console here
I'm gonna just go and find a spinner the
product oh no now that one there we go
spinner and let's see if we can find it
there we go so we have no spinner
instances here I'm just go ahead and
create one really really quickly I'm
going to call it reservations demo and
that's going to give you an instance ID
here you have the options of whether you
want a global deployment or
multi-regional deployment or regional
deployment and it's going to be on the
safe side here I'm gonna use a small
deployment here with us central one and
you can select the number of nodes or
you want now spinner is horizontally
scalable basic
you know there's a little guidance here
that tells you how much load each of the
node can actually handle so a node can
handle up to 10,000 QPS for the reefs
and 2,000 compares for the right if you
need more you just increase the number
of the nodes and I'm just now go ahead
and create this new instance and once I
get there it's going to ask me to create
a new database so within the instance I
can create multiple databases I'm just
going to create a new database called
reservations similarly to what josh has
done and we have this nice UI that you
can actually use to create the table I'm
going to call a reservation table if I
don't make any mistakes I'm going to
create a new ID field here with the
string as the is the type there we go
and UUID size 36 characters so that's
what I'm going to use and let me just
scroll down and make this now no one and
I'm going to go ahead and create another
ID that is called the reservation name
is that right yeah and it's a string as
well not no and then I can of course
continue and just make sure I have the
primary key and click on create and I
should be doing
yeah real developers don't use user
interfaces what's this about man ok can
I use text plays a console actually you
can so up here you can actually edit as
text so we can actually show you the
actual DDL that's necessary to create
this table and you can run this video
against spend a database from a script
or from my API when you're provisioning
a new database okay so I'll go ahead and
create it and while it's creating and
that's done reservations I got
everything right all right very cool so
to access this database i'm gonna be
using spring data
sabrina is really really cool so rather
than writing a lot of the boilerplate
code on the contributors to create a new
interface called reservation
repository ready to go i'm going to
expand the paging and sorting repository
here for the type of entity type of
reservation and the key type of a string
there you go now that string run string
don't even come from I do not know there
you go alright so there we go and that
is going to give you CR you D axis to
the spinner database that has pagination
support and sorting support just like
that so that's an interface spring data
will automatically provide an object at
runtime that implements the interface
and provides those methods for you yep
so what I'm going to do then is to just
show you how this work
prostitution work I'm going to create a
spanner runner that will implement the
application runner as well just like
that and I need to get used to you know
Joshua's keyboard here with the
implementation and what I'm going to do
is to just inject the repository in so
I'm gonna do private final what is the
code reservation repository I'm gonna
call it repo
and then of course I need to get this
into the constructor so there we go
once I have the repository I can do all
of the basic operations so for example I
can delete all the records from the
Spenard database if I want to every
startup of the application you shouldn't
do it I'm gonna do it for the demo and
and I'm going to also do a stream here
of maybe a few names I'm gonna say Josh
hi ray and my awesome co-worker tisha as
well and for each of the names that we
got I'm going to do a map function here
I'm going to create the new reservation
object like that and because we need to
generate this UID string I'm just going
to generate the UID to random UID to
string and then I'm going to pass the
naming okay and then for every one of
this reservation that we created I'm
just gonna map it to the repo safe
method so this code to save the data
into the spender repository and then for
each one of them can't use my favorite
logger in production which we
system.out.print line this is what we do
all the time all right very cool and
finally the last piece of the puzzle is
well let's I'm going to you I'll just do
the control wise all right there we go
there goes the gdb C stuff and we need
to get rid of this import on the top as
well because I removed the dependency
right so let me get rid of that and
final piece of the puzzle is to actually
connect to the spanner database properly
so I'm going to again get rid of these
things and since I pour in the spanner
starter for spring data what I can do is
to refer to the spinner instance ID
which is reservations
- demo and then of course I need to
specify the database I'm trying to
connect to which is just reservations
and all these should just connect up to
spinner with CRE d-axis
with object mapping and I'm not very
confident that this is just going to
work is that simple it should be yes
that's it's hard to follow after you do
so you're gonna stop stop entry wrong
and let's see if this actually works
this is really scary so behind the
scenes were establishing the
authentication and connecting to spanner
and this is trying to connect it via our
conference Wi-Fi here and there you go
there is a reservation objects that is
actually being stored in spanner just to
prove to you I didn't fake this I'm
gonna go back to the database I just
created I'm going to go to the
reservation table I'm going to go to the
data here you can actually browse and
there we go we got the data that we just
created
now of course printed I can do much much
more if you want to create a service
actually expose the spanner data via a
restful interface what I can do is to go
back to the repository here and I just
need to add an annotation here called
the rest repository there we go where is
it got repository rest resource yeah so
just by adding this one under tation all
of the co-led functionalities can be
exposed via a restful interface I'm
going to another reload here
just stop it wrong yeah it's going to
restart the application again you
establish the connection to spanner and
then expose this unless you're the
interface I'm just going to open up the
terminal here hopefully you can see it
I'm going to curl localhost:8080
so this is what we are connected to and
you can see that we have endpoint that
is automatically exposed and we can go
to reservations in point and of course I
should be able to see oh the spinner
data that I actually configure to map
now this is CRE D what that means is you
can also post into this endpoint and it
will save the data to spinner in a
global fashion that's awesome so now we
have highly available consistent
globally available state of persistence
and storage I can build the ultimate cat
picture website right this is the kind
of technology that we need in 2018 this
is what we're here for this is what
we're bringing to bear a whole warehouse
full of computers is to be able to build
cat picture websites at scale so I know
that as this site scales out there's
going to be more people that are going
to connect to it I'm gonna have more
services surely this is just the
beginning of a long and wonderful
journey to production and we can have
other micro services I gonna talk to
each other as we add more users to the
system we de lose the system with more
traffic we're going to see
more people hitting the surface and
we're gonna be we're gonna want to know
how requests flow from one node to
another in the system how they move from
one micro service to another and this is
a very common use case especially as you
start to conduct more and more data over
the wire using micro services you need
to be able to understand where something
happened right you've heard the you've
heard it said before that moving to
micro services is like making every
production incident a murder-mystery we
have to figure out what happened right
we need to understand where latency is
we need to find out where there's a
problem and one way to do this is to use
distributed tracing as popularized you
know fittingly by the tapper paper
published by Google back in 2011
distribute tracing in theory is very
simple for every request that enters or
exits the system at every ingress or
egress in the system we have a unique ID
that gets added to the message if it's
not there already and it gets
perpetuated if it is there so we take a
message look at the unique ID and then
we make sure that we send another
outgoing message we add that same ID
that correlation ID allows us to then
you know record the the receipt of that
message and then see where that message
has been later on right we can publish
information about where that message has
been later on in theory it's very simple
but imagine all the things you have to
do to our instrument all your code to be
aware of this well in spring card we
have an SPI called spring cloud sleuth
sleuth like a detective right like
Sherlock Holmes spring cot sleuth is a
distributed tracing SPI and there are
different implementations of which I
think the spring cloud GCP Google Cloud
stack trace stack driver trace
implementation is one of their best so
we're going to use that here for our
application I need to go to my build and
add spring cloud GCP starter trace and
we'll add the org spring framework cloud
dependencies as before I did what is a
geek framework ring somebody alright
here we're almost there almost there
look at that okay so we've got now
spring cloud GCV starter trace that's on
the console it's on they built that's
really all I need to do but remember
it's gonna plug into spring code sleuth
by default spring card sleuth captures
one out of every ten requests because
you're not gonna see you're not gonna
need to see every single request in
order to understand what's happened
remember this is all about online
lemon tree what's happening right now
and you'll see the emergent behavior of
your system in the patterns you don't
need to you don't need to endorse that
you want to capture every single request
of every single node in the logging
system instead it's by default ratcheted
down to one out of every ten or 0.1 but
we're gonna ratchet it up to 1.0 so that
we can in our stage demo here see
everything quickly now I'm gonna drive
some traffic to this end point using a
trace runner which is just going to be a
thing that implements application runner
and we'll use this spring framework rest
template now the rest template is
another template object like the JDBC
temple that we looked at earlier that
allows us to make easy rest calls it
should be calls to other services and
I'm going to factory an instance of that
beam I'm gonna tell spring to vend and
is an instance of that beam of this
object in this factory method so Springs
gonna see this beam it's gonna see that
we have spring cloud sleuth on the class
path it's gonna instrument this client
is h-2b client with an interceptor that
is aware of outgoing requests so now I
can say for int I equals 0 I is less
than 10 I plus plus and then I'm just
gonna say this dot rest template get for
entity HTTP localhost 8080 for slash
reservation so I'm going to call myself
basically and I'm gonna tell spring
cloud sleuth I'm gonna tell the rest him
but rather to give me a payload of type
string back so the result will be this
here and I'm just gonna log that out
system out result result like so now
that's gonna be fine but remember we're
making requests from a service on the
command line basically when the
application starts up there's no trace
context at the moment so I'm gonna
simulate a trace context normally you'd
have that if you have if you had one
micro service where the rest api calling
another you'd see that but we don't have
that here so i'm gonna tell spring cloud
sleuth to initiate a span write trace
client in tracing parlance you have the
trace which is the aggregate journey of
all the requests going from A to Z right
from A to B to C to D that whole thing
is called it's just one trace you have
one trace ID each hop in the journey
each leg of the journey is called a span
so you have multiple span IDs and one
trace ID so there we go I started the
application I made a number of different
requests you can see that all here
reflected in the console now if we go
back to Google Cloud oh I'm gonna search
for it trace
awesome tres list sure that works deep
dive so you can see that I've got one
request are got a overarching request
that starts with that trades client and
then a number of subordinate requests
right that were executed in successive
order so if I click on this I can see
the top trace client thing took 1.7
seconds 1.7 seconds to make all those
requests and then I can see pairs here's
the outgoing thing and the response
outgoing thing in response if I look at
that I can see the timestamps they the
headers the context about the request
what end pointed head and if I had
enabled stack stack driver trace logging
then I would see correlated logging here
as well let's see view logs so here we
have all that on the con on the console
readily available just for our
dependency in the application now that
said I've got tracing and it's working
just fine now I have observability I can
see more that's what's happening at the
in the system at runtime now I can feel
a little bit more confident when I want
to integrate this with other services
out there globally consistent and
globally available those spanner is the
last thing I want is to hand out
credentials to partners and other people
that need to depend upon upon my API for
them to get my data instead I'd much
prefer to broadcast that data so that
they can consume it in their
applications and here this is a natural
case for messaging or integration
there's a lot of good options out there
I could where I saw inclined stand-up a
patchy kafka cluster certainly but
there's a very nice choice here in
Google cloud called Google cloud pub/sub
so I'm gonna use that instead and it's
fairly straightforward we're gonna go to
our build and we're gonna add spring
cloud GCP starter pub/sub org spring
framework cloud and now I'm going to
build a thing that's gonna start up and
produce some messages and another thing
that's going to start up and consume the
message let's create a rest controller
here at rest controller producer rest
controller and whenever somebody hits
his endpoint we'll make it a get because
you know no time for a post and we're
going to say that wants to send void
publish and we use the pub/sub templates
I'm going to say a private final pub/sub
template in the template
I'll inject into my constructor as
normal and I'll say this template.dot
published I'm gonna send it to a topic
called reservations which I have it yet
initialize and we'll come back to that
and the message I'll send is hello name
right and the name is the path variable
here in the method definition so path
variable string name there we are and
this returns a listenable future of type
string so I'm going to actually assign
that result to my method here I'll just
tell spring to mend that for me so I'll
say return this that that okay now
that's my producer on the consumer side
I'm gonna have a consumer runner that
implements application runner and the
consumer runner is going to start up and
it's going to take advantage of the
public sub tab template here to
subscribe so I'll say at subscribe in
this method and I'll register a message
listener so this template dot subscribe
and I'm going to subscribe to the
reservations subscription so these are
not the same thing there's a decoupling
between the thing which you can do which
you poll for messages and the thing that
actually takes incoming messages in just
versus a you know whatever so we're
gonna print out the message received
this message dot get data dot to string
utf-8 and then we're gonna explicitly
acknowledge the consumption of the
message otherwise that message will get
read delivered later on so I'm gonna
take care of that now now before we can
run this code interesting though it is
we need to actually configure these
topics and subscriptions here in Google
cloud pub/sub so I'm gonna go down here
to pops up down there here we are and
I'm gonna go to the topics column and we
have create a topic called reservations
which is what we said we had create that
and then that's gonna need a
corresponding subscription so I'll
create a new subscription and that's
gonna be called reservation subscription
and I'll hit create what's with that in
place I have everything I need to be
able to run this application let's go
ahead and give it a go and see what we
get so now once that's up and running I
can hit curl localhost:8080 forward
slash publish forward slash Google next
alright that good yeah I think so looks
ok yeah is it running there we go we got
a response get oh yeah did you add the
component
for the runner yeah there it is consumer
winner did I misspell something oh I did
misspell something
it's yeah here I spent I said
reservations subscription okay there we
go
awkward very awkward sorry about that
that's not too bad for I'm just making a
simple mistake like that that's awkward
oh I could do better these cat picture
websites won't get to production with
that kind of that kind of sloppy coding
so there we go oh by the way you saw the
miss message there's a message I that I
it's been retro actively consumed come
on yeah yeah oh there there are these
there's that yeah there's hello next now
I'm going to send it again because I've
got it queued and we should see if we go
down here there it is again
right so that's not bad not bad pretty
good it's pretty good now of course we
have a lot of different functionalities
here that you can actually use spring
wait and if spring has an obstruction
for it we would love to have some kind
of a nice layer underneath page so that
you can consume the GCP services very
easily we saw it for spanner
we actually have other than other
integrations for configurations for
accessing cloud storage that we can
store as much data as you want but if
you don't have that kind of abstraction
if you want to use some kind of API just
out of the box from Google cloud you can
actually do that too so for example
there's no abstraction to use a vision
API for that matter to analyze the
pictures that you can upload so what I'm
going to do is to for example consume
the vision API that we have so the first
thing that we need to do is to actually
add the dependency for using that client
library and that's pretty easily done
all I need to do is come back here I'm
going to use the Google cloud vision API
to do this so there we go
religion vision yeah and it's gonna be
under come down kugel cloud there we go
and because all the dependencies are
being managed by the bomb what that
means is that we manage all the
compatible versions for you so you don't
have to explicitly declare any versions
here we will transitively
import anything that's necessary and you
order for this API to work so once I
have this API imported then I can go
ahead and use spring to potentially a
factory a client so I'm going to go back
here I'm going to use the ping
annotation here I'm going to produce a
image annotated client this is the
client I need to use to talk to the
vision API so I'm going to uncover the
image annotation client and of course I
can go ahead and return this client
essays but our starter actually can
figure out the environment that you're
running in and because we have Google
App Engine we got Canaries engine where
we got local environments you might be
running this I'm praying for that matter
so what we do is we automatically try to
understand what credentials we can use
and they will give you this thing called
the credentials provider so that you can
use it to bootstrap your client
libraries with the right credentials
that you configured for your spring
application so I'm going to go ahead and
use this so I'm going to create a spring
annotated client I'm going to make sure
that I've got the settings in there so
this is only thing that you have to do
which is to use a custom setting I'm
going to set the credential provider
just like that it's going to you know
add an exception here now here's the
thing this client is actually a heavy
client what that means is that we try to
keep the singleton and however it does
implement Alto closeable what that means
is that when the spring booth
application stops will automatically
shut down the clients and close all the
connections for you so are basing things
will just work now to test this thing
out I'm going to also create a little
controller here with the rest controller
I'm going to call it which we call a
vision controller how's that yep yeah
and I'm going to also for this one with
me the post mapping so I'm going to call
it vision so I'm going to try to create
the controller that I can post a picture
to right and this is going to return
let's say return a string and I'm going
to code this vision and I'm going to
texting them the image upload as a
parameter and to upload a file in spring
what you need to do is to use multi-part
file and then code this image and that's
it now we think here I can also go ahead
and just inject the client I just
created so I'm going to be private final
image annotated client there we go and
then code is the client and of course I
need to get this into the constructor as
well there we go okay so from the client
this opus trap this will just connect up
to the client sorry for the vision API
so I can do is I can go ahead and say
client batch annotate the image and from
here I need a little e so we can use
collections
singleton list and I need to passing a
notate image request so we got use the
builders here so what is in this request
what we need to set the image so this
image will have the bytes that we just
uploaded so we need to use this pewter
for the image and I'm going to again set
the content and that is a by string
which I'm going to copy the bytes from
the image here to get bytes and that's
pretty much it
now there are many different things that
the vision API can do for those for
example we can detect what scenes are
the pictures we can actually extract
text from the image as well for every
one of those we can just add a feature
detection necessary for this particular
functionality so I'm going to go ahead
and just add a feature that will detect
the labels so basically understanding
what is inside the picture so without
one Wilson's going to label detection of
course I can add more but that's pretty
much it now this is going to return the
response I'm going to convert it to a
string and merchants now return this
from the endpoint the API just the API
just rolls right off the tongue look at
just ferry yep yeah yeah so happening so
let's see if this actually will work so
if when this application restarts we
should have a vision endpoint that will
take a file upload and but then for that
we need a picture yet have one I do my
friend yeah I've got one right here I'm
gonna be happy
desktop cat of course so let's look at
the picture so we know what we're
dealing with here it's a it's a cat it's
a cat everybody it's a it's a cat yeah
okay yes that's very nice yeah what do
we get all right yeah yeah Wikipedia
there we go so there you go so you know
what you now to find it it's on the
desktop there yeah all right so there
you go I'm going just go to the desktop
here so that's easy gone through a curl
- f so that's going to you upload the
cat picture read from the the file
system and we are post it to the vision
endpoint and of course somebody thinks
it's which is work neither do i but oh
there we go so we just posted this
picture to the endpoint which then
talked to the vision API that's boost
rabbi spring and we can actually see
that it detected that this is 99%
a cat yeah for sure yeah it's a smoke to
medium-sized cat as well as a cat like
memo bump
she's a cat yeah yeah but but we can
also proceed that the type of the cat is
63 percent sure that's a European sure
here yeah very interesting yeah that was
pretty cool roll right on yeah our cat
picture website is getting better and
better now that's it I think we're
missing some important stuff for me I'm
missing some important stuff first of
all this is an enterprise e cloud scale
you know a kind of application wouldn't
be much of an application if we didn't
have suitable ASCII art banners so I'm
gonna make sure that we we address that
right now by adding a custom banner dot
txt to my application curl downloads
reservation service source main
resources the painter is did this thing
that you see when you start the optical
fix that right here okay so there we go
we have good a scart banners already you
can see in the application when the
application starts up it says spring
right right there it's very very well
done but that said sometimes if you want
to change it and that's okay if you want
to change it you should feel free and I
just showed you how I'm gonna copy that
text file I've got this text file here
called banner dot txt right it's in mind
it's in my application directory I'm
gonna now go to the command line here CD
downloads reservation service maven
clean spring - boot call and run wait
not bad right I controlled seated so we
can see the results there's nyan cat
getting better getting better I think
that's a good a good thing a good
feature in addition to our cloud native
system that thing there is that said
there is one more thing I'd like to talk
about just just one more thing we you
may have heard about Kane ADA if anybody
here hear about Kane native in the last
few days yeah so we at pivotal have been
working very closely with our friends
here at Google and we've got a project
called riff riff is for functions get it
riff is for functions it's an it's a
recursive acronym friends don't think
too much about it your head will explode
it's a it's for functions it function as
a service platform built K natively on
top of K native and it we debuted the
day of the launch right as soon as there
was a the ability to talk about it
publicly we released the version that's
built on top of it and that platform is
available it's open source it's Apache 2
license you can download it from Project
rift at i/o it's here and the docs of
course speak to how to run it on local
machine on mini coop and on gke right
which is a nice place to run your your
workloads so we have gke based riff on
top of k native i've got that running in
our google cloud account in my Google
Cloud console that's that's already
deployed and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to show you how to deploy a
function based application to this work
to this this runtime now I've got a
couple examples here I'm gonna go to my
console that's let's clean up some of
the noise here I've got a couple
examples here I'm gonna go to my desktop
I'm gonna look at the the butiful GCP
riff function I'm gonna open this up in
my IDE and this is a spring cloud
function based application spring cloud
function is an abstraction that allows
you to write functions that work in an
agnostic way independent of any
particular function runtime so you can
use what's that other company in Seattle
[Music]
BWS something that other company they
have functions as well that other one
the other one in Redmond they have one
they have functions as well and of
course RIF is a great choice right so we
RIF is a I think the most interesting
option here we're gonna open up this
spring card function based application
normally in order to run your functions
on these other platforms you need an
adapter but you don't need that for this
so we have
very simple function that allows you to
take a string it's literally just a job
util function it's a Java 8 function API
so we're gonna say given a string in
uppercase it very very simple trivial
example and I simplified it down to a
lambda like this right that's what that
doesn't gonna simplified it it again to
a method reference like that so very
very trivial you know globally scalable
uppercase thing okay so there was in a
simple example and now I'm gonna deploy
this to riff here I've got a little
script called build and what build is
gonna do is it's gonna all this is to
say I'm going to build it copy the jar
to the root of directory
check it in then I'm gonna get my
project ID for Google Cloud I've got a
function name it's called uppercase I'm
gonna delete the function with riff if
it's already existing and then I'm gonna
create a new one here you've using riff
function create Java passing in the name
of the function pointing it to the get
repository because that's the way Kay
native works it's one of the ways Kay
native works we're putting it to the
artifacts which in this case is the jar
and we're telling it to run the handler
called uppercase now uppercase is the
bean name here write the string cloud
function bean and then we're telling it
to pull the image from the Google
container repository and the URL here so
let's run this script it'll build and
little deploy you know actually this is
actually a spring with application right
yeah it's a spring boot application so
everything we've looked at spring cut
GCP all these things you can use within
that function you can call them just
like you would any other spring boobest
based application now the application is
up and running we can see riff service
list okay there's a some kid native is
really new yet my friends so there's
some weirdness there but we can see that
it's got upper case now I'm going to say
Kubb CTL get pods and we can see it says
upper case and we've got three zero out
of three
so get pods again three out of three
yeah so now I'm gonna run this this
application using riff run and this
one's actually a fairly straightforward
I'm gonna say I've got a function named
upper case I want to call the function
gateway using this command line but you
could just as easily call your get the
URL and the host in the port and then
send a fungus ender request to it using
curl or something else so I'm gonna say
invoke that that function passing in a
payload of type hello Kay native
get the result back so let's try this
run rerun curl and there we go we got
hello Canada not bad huh
yeah I mean it's just upper case it's
very well yeah well but this just upper
casing a few strings a few bites I mean
is that what you use service for I've
got a whole warehouse full of computers
if I want to just upper case strings
that's what I want to do what well King
upper case something else I mean what
else can you do with this I can upper
case a cat what yeah the copy sure that
we just had yeah not a word cat but the
actual picture yeah how do you do okay
so we've got another function here
desktop upper cat opera cat yeah totally
different totally different application
so what do you do is hit upper cat
function that you can Co from G okay and
you can too so I'm gonna build it just
as before we'll hit build okay so it's
gonna deploy just as before get pushed
all that stuff you're pushing on are pre
cat function yeah well I you know it's
it's open towards others are free to use
it so now if we go to coop CTL get pods
will see that it's spinning up in it
three or four yeah do a watch watch yep
there we go okay
now we're cookin yeah alright here we go
initializing now what does actually do
how do you uppercase a cat well there's
a lot of it's very sophisticated ray
it's very complicated I'm not sure you'd
understand it knows no I don't worry
yeah okay so it's deployed okay we've
got this application we got three or
three instances of the upper cat service
in the cloud now I'm gonna invoke it so
I'm going to say riff run same thing and
here
what are we just gonna say riff service
invoke upper cat passing in header
content type text playing I'm sending
the bytes it doesn't really matter I'm
sending the bytes from this file cat jpg
it's the same one right so open this
there it is and that's the same cat okay
it's the same cat the poor cat look at
him look at him that that's scaredy cat
right there so I'm gonna send that cat
into the cloud and be you know
transformed okay so cat riff run okay
and then once the data comes out it's
gonna be output to JSON there's a key in
the JSON called cat I'm gonna uh I'm
gonna extract that key with JQ and then
a 64 - decoded and then I'll put that to
a jpg file which I don't have here right
so there's a no upper cat JPEG all right
you ready
I'm hoping this work I'm hoping this
works I don't know what magically happy
honey okay yes that was really not done
and there it is all right very nice
that's how you uppercase a cat now we
have an application it's good it's good
but I think we do need one one more
thing yeah one more thing I like the ass
guard that we looked at before okay yeah
but I do want improve upon it it's 2018
yeah and we can uppercase cats we can do
anything so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna replace the a scart one more time
since we have the time with an animated
gif because you know that's how I roll
so Carl downloads reservation service
source main resources banner dot gif did
you get rid of the other previous I
think I do yeah awkward banner dot txt
all right now back may even clean spring
- boot call and run and try it again
huh very nice very nice
no it does take a few seconds to start
does it yeah I know that I know it takes
like 30 seconds to start up I don't even
care totally worth it absolutely worth
it you should be stopping a production
great applications and updating them
with a skirt right now well my friend
yeah I think we're just about out of
time
yeah but uh just about why so we got so
let's take a look at let's go back what
did you have the thing right here here
we are yeah so we went through quite a
few things today a few yeah just a few
there are a number of different starters
you can actually use like I said
configuration in the storage logging so
what we can do is to correlate your logs
directly with trace as well
all of these are fully integrated with
spring and spring boot and there's a ton
of resources you can use we have the
project homepage the documentation the
source coding examples we got short code
lab we got long collab we have a
bootcamp tomorrow as well you're welcome
to join and of course we'll have other
things from a project RIF and in Josh's
favorite place after production which is
start that spring that IO will take 8
questions thank you so much thanks for
being here thank you
[Applause]
[Music]